[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich gehe drei machen
da machen okay an und ihr verschiedene
jungpflanze zum opfer und zwei paletten
bei nazis und und kokos und zu machen
nur keinen pflanzen flecker und es immer
von görlitz nach unten
los santos cd ist 24 jahre alt er ist
mit einer kleinen pobla sie geboren
worden
diese zerebrale fehlbildung ist der
grund für seine motorischen und
sprachlichen einschränkungen eine
reguläre lehre war für ihn nicht möglich
dennoch bekam er hier in neukirchen
kanton thurgau in einer gärtnerei eine
zweijährige lehrstelle die auf seine
fähigkeiten zugeschnitten war
in der schweiz bieten zwar viele
betriebe lehrstellen für menschen mit
einer behinderung an
tatsächlich findet aber nur jeder vierte
absolvent eine stelle auf dem ersten
arbeitsmarkt
die große mehrheit arbeite den
geschützten werkstätten
julian hatte glück nach seiner lehre vom
betrieb übernommen zu werden
viktor geschwend führt seit 30 jahren
die gärtnerei mit rund 15 angestellten
und lehrlingen
wie kam es dazu dass lucy an hier
angefangen hat präsident von der
musikschulleiter gemeint du da um zu
unterrichten büste dann ist sie einfach
kränkt sie stehen einmal doch stand eine
seite sie würde gerne material zu
whiskey der luzerner überzeugt mich halt
will erhält die schränke aber der kerl
ebit und der macht eigentlich das
maximum wonach an machte er das
eigentlich jeden tag um mit man absolut
begeistert ich schaffe ich motiviert ist
ausglich meist lohnt mittlerweile heraus
in schalke kennengelernt und
funktioniert der zweifache gärtnerische
arbeiten uc4 töpfl viele mit erde
pflanzen in töpfen begierde
verantwortung für den baumschutz und
küsse
das macht er sehr gut ab und zwar
vergisst normaler plant aber da ist kein
problem natürlich die schränke es sich
so dass ich am luzerner kann fünftes mal
gehe will ich das andere normale
lehrling kg ozean würde ich meine
halbzeit prozent vor der gärtnerische ab
da kann er erledige schnitt sehr viel
aber was ist global realistisch
es ist verständlich dass sie mir dann so
ein lehrer der in der weg war nicht die
freie wirtschaft karussell und ein
fachgeschäft
[Musik]
dank seiner arbeit in der gärtnerei kann
lucie an ein selbstständiges und
selbstbestimmtes leben führen
er erhält eine iv rente und von seiner
arbeit in der gärtnerei bekommt er einen
kleinen rom lausanne wohnt mit seinen
eltern in der gemeinde neukirch ganz in
der nähe der gärtnerei zum mittagessen
geht er immer nach hause wo er sich gut
entspannen kann
[Musik]
sein vater andrasch war früher
musiklehrer und ist seit seiner
pensionierung hausmann gute regula ist
profi musikerin und unterrichtet geige
bruder moritz studiert biologie die
freizeit verbringt er mit seiner
freundin bei der familie lucian ist hier
gut aufgehoben
wirklich sehr dankbar das ist so das
große los und sogar hält das schaffen
will
zum schwer möglichkeit für mich sieht
das erinnere institution hat können aber
das wäre nicht das richtige für einmal
knapp zwei wochen in einer institution
und wenn ich noch zweitägiges sms oder
seit liebe mama was soll ich hier hier
sind alle behindert also setzt sich
nicht wohl gefühlt
ja und da wird der sehr gut breit vor
der ampel ein team hat große
fortschritte machte sich noch entwickelt
die letzten 230 merckx im wortschatz zum
beispiel ganz anders geworden
und das ist
ja
glaubt sie nicht stärke ist seine
offenheit sowohl nach links als set
achtung strahlungsgefahr einfach seines
offenes wesen und ich glaube das gilt zb
im oder warum siege und seien sie mit
dem er die einfach wienerisch 790 minute
irgendwie imponiere das ist nicht nötig
wir glauben sehr wenig schlechte
erfahrungen gemacht er ist damit
aufgewachsen im dome wo ihn akzeptiert
so wienerisch herrlich einfach der
lotion mit conti nur halb so wienerisch
wird so völlig akzeptiert
schwechat sich gern kritisieren das
nicht so gern
das sind heben schwerer relativ
eingeschränkt wenn man es machen mit
freut sich um dann ist wieder weg
fanatiker fernsehen ich muss genau so
stark dass cm rufen macht glücklich
alles ganz genau ordnet es glaubt das
buch der aufmacher die sicherheit alles
klingt nach hinten ist etliche mal also
gärtner werte bis mit pflanzen und
danach mekka cannabispflanze
let's golf von mexiko erwachsene die
kette und logistik und mit denen ich
wirklich lustig
[Gelächter]
lucian ist ein langsamer arbeiter und
das ist natürlich eine große gut will
vom viktor dass er das halt in kauf
nimmt
ich weiß von schulkollegen womit dem ezb
ziel gegangen sind wo gesetzt nicht
gefunden hat ja sich sehr schwierig also
mir hat einfach ein riesiges gilt kann
dann fix wenn lucy an irgendwann
anspruchsvollere aufgaben übertragen
wir sind nicht möglich wieder feststellt
dass wieder klärt und die arbeiter er
eigentlich am liebsten macht und da auch
events monoton ist das heißt das wenn
ein ganzer tag wohl fühlen und begehren
das macht der eigentlich am liebsten
kann er es machen wollen sie den tisch
und das macht wütend
klar werden wir schnell gestresst wenn
reiz mir ist die sache machen und sich
offen oder wunder bisschen falsch machen
glaubt dass für ihn steht so wie sieht
lucia und schneller
schäfer und restlos glücklich sagt
meisterschaft
die familie ist ein ruhepol mit viel
spiel machen aber fühlt sich der show
einfach golf gucke mich ein sehr schönes
familie fällt es gibt kaum lud die
tommys ich glaube er fühlt sich wirklich
wohl dahinter sehr deutsch
ja es ist michael essig mit der familie
wohne ja und und mir kommt mir kein
mensch krank ist pater michael ballack
aus wenn es warm ist im sommer und die
city bkk wird die emission mit der
familie csi
ja
war die richtig hallo
so wie heute
[Musik]
regelmäßig besucht lucy an seinen onkel
und götti lukas niederer in zürich lukas
ist der zwillingsbruder von julians
mutter und ist von beruf
schulsozialarbeiter die beiden haben
viele gemeinsame interessen
als er später ausgewählt worden und das
ist schon ganz weg sie ich habe mir sehr
viel sagt selber gemacht und sehr viel
kontakt mit mir auf zum konzert gala
fußball macho
eine wochenend verbringen das auch
deutlich und so auch gemacht
es ist ja los mit dem nachbau sind
sauber sind der winter sind kaputt
gegangen
warum die schönsten bärengarten
ja sowieso
deshalb des vereins gibt
[Musik]
mich erstaunt immer wieder der davids
wohneinheit die fröhlichkeit waren immer
wieder einfache branche dort mit seiner
zeit mit sache wenn er sich über leid
dass er sich sehr viele gedanken macht
wirklich sehr reizt allgemeinwissen mich
immer wieder stimmt auch ich mal wieder
recht wissbegierig ist neue sachen
können und hat wirklich die fröhlichkeit
war die unbekümmertheit worden und tags
darauf in der app ist brechend ist für
mich die nachricht von kaffee
[Musik]
red
bay
er ist sehr offen berichtete direkt er
ich habe mit ihm über alles schweizer
über alles mitgemacht nicht seine über
fußball über musik reden als mit sehr
ähnlichen presse dass er statt mir vor
dem her waren wir im ressort familie
erläuterte mir sicher nächsten vor allem
cervelo betrags ist nur die rote zone
rasenplatz unglücklich macht sich das an
[Musik]
ich finde es sehr schön dass er selber
so aktiv ist und um sie in die
freizeitgestaltung ersetzen sind alle
fußballmanager dort jungwacht oder dort
viele besucher von mir ich gar kein
kontakt mit gott jetzt nur krause und so
geht's los zu machen und ich gemacht
und für mechaniker lässig dass dir zum
beispiel musik ich muss schneller bist
du dass du sowieso das spiel nicht so
schnell kann ein auto tödlich das wetter
und er hat ein thema auf mallorca ist
aber es zunächst fühle
wir müssen auf quax eine ganze
kollektion irland leider sind sie
verwechselt und ist hin auf buback
systeme die eine familie sind egal
macher der hochvolatile trinken
die teams werden
[Musik]
sie trug sich zweimal und habe mir als
mit leiter um einen teil der geldbuße
und habe schätze den sehr motiviert mich
immer freut sich megane in liebe und der
gang auf die asche
ich verstehe ihn sehr
[Musik]
entgegen seiner anfänglichen
befürchtungen hatte verschwand mit lucia
nicht mehr aufwand als mit anderen
lehrlingen
der grund sei dass lucy an motiviert
zuarbeiter scheine verantwortungsvoll
und mit seiner offenen art auch bei den
angestellten beliebt sei ob er noch
einmal einen menschen mit einer
behinderung ausbilden und anstellen
würde dass wir die ritter mache wenn ich
es gleich viel wie beim luzian aber ich
werde jetzt ein zweiter oder dritter
das kommt für mich eigentlich nicht die
frau also es wäre einfach dem wenn jetzt
der lucian fertig werden kann ich mir
vorstelle zum peter seufert nicht ein
zweiter oder dritter oder vierter diese
personen will
der betriebshof an die stadt ich finde
die eine person user größe da ist für
mich kein thema dass ich gut wenn über
zu motiviert dies dem bin ich das auch
und mieter dazu erleichtern ich hoffe
ich gestellt dass jetzt wieder thurgauer
gärtner diversität wohlfahrt entlud mit
berechtigung mehr stark mit
verschiedensten berechtigung
also ich glaube dass wir das wir klebt
und natürlich platzieren
da glaubt die einfach mehr
aufklärungsarbeit leistet das mit der
note täter so glücklich themen schwele
nimmt das probieren
aber ich glaube die schlussendlich ist
es halt wirklich persönlich bin ich war
einfach nur funktionieren und der
jugendliche oder die person die man
wählen
der passt einfach zu seinen platz
gefunden diesem team mine und
der dörfer bliebe so lange er kann das
einfach körperlich machen
solange dem platz
[Musik]
lucia und seine eltern sind sich einig
dass die feste anstellung in der
gärtnerei ihm eine solide basis gibt und
lebensqualität bedeutet sowohl beruflich
als auch privat ist lucian bestens
integriert hp macht sich 25 20 25 10 uhr
sich rossi
heute hat viktor schwend lucy an für das
weihnachtsessen seines betriebes zu
hause ab es ist ihm wichtig loos jan
immer auf augenhöhe zu begegnen und ihm
dieselbe anerkennung entgegenzubringen
wie auch seinen anderen angestellten
[Musik]
ja es ist für mich wichtig erst die
leute gar nicht immer schafft das mal an
korte stimme kennt deshalb möchten also
verbindlich binnenklima
aber es ist der einfach wird der biz
werdich zuruf statt 7
die anteile neu aufgestellt sind
[Musik]
was wünscht sich regula für die zukunft
ihres sohnes glücklich dass er nicht so
wienerisch dass er das gefühl hat er
verpasst
mit dem leben
das schöne arbeit wird das ist auch sehr
wichtig gute freunde wird immer hart
seine kollegen aber die werden jetzt die
werden irgendwann ein schwindler ich
hoffe dass wieder neu finden wo inhalt
307 umfeld von re zeigt konsumenten
immer sind dass er weiterhin
unterstützen
moritz für in die kabine zuversichtlich
[Musik]